[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
so what are we doing today walter
we're talking about reflections on cop
and other things and other things let's
open with a word of prayer
our father in heaven thank you very much
for giving us the opportunities to have
these discussions
we ask that you bless the discussion and
also enlighten our minds in jesus name
amen amen
martin the last events will be rapid
ones isn't that so yeah
and the very final
final cherry on top
will be the implementation of the mark
of the beast
and i'm starting to think that these
rapid movements will not always be very
visible
yes because
you know
when you have societies that work in
secret
then that's the catchphrase
secret exactly secret numbers are
supposed to see
and when somebody walks in secret and
someone doesn't know about it then he's
inclined to shout conspiracy theory
so let's have a look at some run-up
interesting things that are happening in
the world besides cop 26 we'll get there
and one of the
interesting things that is happening is
this company called meta
and meta is a new creation
a
umbrella company
that embraces the social media
companies yeah it's like facebook and
instagram and whatsapp
correct so they still keep their names
but they fall under a new
mega
umbrella company called
meta
now here's an article in cbn news
the christian perspective
and it says
meta will no longer allow ads targeting
politics
religion
sexual orientation on facebook and
instagram
so
this company
this mega company is not only
a company that contains companies
it is also a censoring board yes it will
decide
what is
correct lawful or what is lawful and
what is not and when i look at some of
these characters that are in controlling
positions
one asks oneself
how
does it happen
that people
of such a nature
become the model thermometer for the
world
which is highly unlikely right
because
the power which they wield
is one
where they will sit in congress under
cross-examination
with a confidence and a power
that cannot be moved even by the most
blatant attacks against what they are
doing i mean you constantly see them
like you say before congress being
grilled
but nothing happens nothing happens they
stay absolutely calm so
the only solution to that martin because
it wouldn't happen with you and me right
no
the only solution is that their power
comes from another source and we've seen
many an occasion
where
we can deduce with a fair amount of
certainty where that power comes from
martin have you had a personal interview
with the pope
no
have i had one
no i don't think we will have one
but these people do right
they are constantly in that forum
so what does this actually mean and
their symbolism is also interesting
this infinity sign on its side which is
also of course
the the same sign that we find in secret
societies
and pope john paul ii actually used it
quite often
when he went like this etc
so mata the newly named parent company
of the social media giant facebook
announced tuesday that early next year
it will no longer allow its advertisers
to target ads on topics
related to politics or other sensitive
issues including religion
and then there's the issue of shadow
banning now we have said quite
some time ago already that even our own
channel is obviously under shadow
banning and shadow banning for a long
time by the fact checkers were put
forward as a conspiracy theory correct
and here's another facts checking
conspiracy theory that is
in the dustbin
because facebook's transparency center
publicly admitted to its shadow banning
habits last month that's interesting
so this is cbn news saying that it is
not a conspiracy
so the national religious broadcasters
report that facebook's shadow banning
policy directly affects biblical
messages on the platform
and you cannot tell the true extent etc
but it says here the true extent of
facebook's content distribution policies
remained cloaked in secrecy
now martin seems like secrecy is the
name of the game right exactly we've
been on the other side of this
if you s if we just look at the
statistics about how when we started the
what's up prof series for instance
what happened there and how
our views were and recommendations of
the video to other people were really
quite good
and even all of a sudden
this started happening and we saw that
curve going down
and then this
conspiracy of shadow banning was
up in the air and now we actually got it
from themselves
that they are doing that
now uh it's this is very very
interesting so this is one of
the
mega companies and their ceos
that are working very closely with uh
other powers including of course
and mainly
i would like to add the vatican yes
so this is part of the plot for the end
time
now here's an article in new scientist
and it says why is facebook changed its
name to meta and what is
the metaverse
facebook has rebranded itself as meta in
an attempt to own the metaverse a
concept for a 3d version of the internet
that a number of companies are working
on
the name was chosen to echo the key
product that zuckerberg hopes facebook
now meta
will be represented by the metaverse the
name for a shared online 3d virtual
space
that a number of companies are
interested in creating as a sort of
future version of the internet
in this future you will be able to
teleport instantly as a hologram
to be at the office without a commute
at a concert with friends
or in your parents living room to catch
up zuckerberg wrote in a letter
announcing facebook's rebranding as meta
now they've done this before
many years ago i gave a lecture called
the beamable sustainable princess
in which
al gore
and prince charles were actually
portrayed in a hell hologram yeah in a
virtual situation
so this is not new technology no
this is just technology that they want
to incorporate into everyday life now
correct
and basically
martin when you go into the details of
what they are doing they are creating a
virtual reality yes
in other words they are creating a world
where you
operate within your imagination
so no matter what happens outside you
create your virtual reality
you can be in a meeting
you can actually in that virtual reality
order food it will be
delivered to you by drone yeah
right correct isn't that great i've also
portrayed this in
some movies like ready player one where
they've got a similar situation that the
metaverse will consist of so in actual
fact the world has been prepared for
this
now martin
what is this based on
is this based on a real world or is this
based on a meta world
it's based on a meta worry
now which ideology in the world
teaches its adherence to create a meta
world
the jesuits there's only one
that's the jesuits
where you in the form of visualization
exactly
enter into in the world of imagination
and then you create your
your reality that's it or you rewrite
reality that's ignacious loyola
spiritual exercises that's exactly what
it's all about so these are ignacian
spirituality
and
you know i don't want to be highly
critical of everything that's happening
in the world out there but
there are some very famous christian
movies that are
or series that are being produced even
currently
where you have
stories of jesus
but a lot of it is based on spiritual
exercises
because there are additions to the
gospel
which through the power of the
imagination have been added to the story
and therefore
they are able to actually steer the ship
in a different direction
ever so slightly ever so slightly for
example you can
you can divert the emphasis from jesus
to mary
you can
[Music]
divert the glory of christ to the
disciples
and you know you can do many of these
things so it is a it is a very dangerous
world in which to live
now when god created this world
did he create a reality
or did he create a virtual reality a
reality it created the reality right
now in movies like the matrix they will
try to tell you that it's not a reality
it's a virtual experience you only think
that it is a reality it's a very
dangerous move
satan has been busy with this kind of
thinking and mind manipulation for a
very very long time exactly and it's
been pulled through to religion
because now a lot of people think that
this that we see is also
not the real thing
this is almost a new age
it is absolutely new age and we can also
see why
spiritual formation is such a dangerous
concept
and i've been receiving quite a number
of letters from people
that are
you know in dire straits that are
destitute and they're seeking help
and
they once
they want spiritual guidance
and they want they're depressed and they
have problems and they need to come out
of these problems
and these so-called christian
methods are based on many of them are
based on spiritual formation
which place you in a virtual reality
and try to divert you from what your
current trend is into another trend
based on virtual reality
it doesn't work like that because we are
not virtual we are actual you actually
have to deal with what's going on all
right now let's say in this virtual
world you are
doing gardening
you'll actually be sitting in your chair
with
a pair of glasses on
that create the 3d experience and you
will be doing everything that you're
doing with your two fingers right
you will be doing whatever it is yeah
they might even
develop some technology that you
actually do something with your hands
but it won't be real it won't be real it
will be virtual
and uh god has placed nature
at our disposal he has created all the
creatures the plants the soil
and he wants us to be active
participants
not in an imaginary world but in a real
world
and the same with our relationship with
god
our relationship with god cannot be a
virtual relationship that's jesuit
thinking
they are constantly
in a virtual world and in that world
they can manipulate minds and
circumstances at their will
but in a real world
you will have to base your spirituality
on this book exactly
and what this book says is reality yes
everything that is added to or removed
is virtual
very very dangerous occult
experience
so
my advice to people would be to become
not more and more involved in these
platforms
but less and less yeah
now let's see how far this goes
pope francis warns against preachers who
sow division online we've had this quote
up before but it fits in with matter yes
because there will be
a very strict way of dealing with this
kind of thing right
exactly
so what will be permissible and will not
be permissible
is not based on the morality of those
ceos
but is based on another morality which
is found at a higher level
namely here in the vatican
so at his general audience on wednesday
pope francis warned against preachers
who sow division and mistrust online
mistrust in whom martin
in him and his methodologies right
and
well he deserves mistrust
didn't the reformation
open up the very issues that led to the
mistrust the reformation brought back
the reality because everybody was living
in a virtual reality not knowing that it
was the antichrist they were even living
in a virtual after world
of screaming souls in purgatory
that was a virtual reality of that time
but it wasn't the reality it was a lie
exactly right it wasn't there it wasn't
in this book
so there's no shortage of preachers who
especially through the new means of
communication can disturb communities
well
preaching the gospel
is disturbing communities
making you think exactly and now we've
seen that already
on this new meta platform or the new
facebook won't happen won't happen
you're not going to be
there's no religion ads it's already
shadow banning anything that has to do
with the bible they're already doing it
so this is very interesting so
when it comes to disturbing communities
it actually should read there
disturbing communities that he has
managed to indoctrinate
into a state of oblivion at this point
in time
now
when you disturb communities by
preaching the truth and the gospel
then you are opening up a debate and
that leads to decisions
and this is where the world is heading
we're heading for a mega conflict that's
it
one which says we will silence your
voice
completely at the point to the point of
death and that you've just mentioned but
thinking and consciousness
is guided by them at this stage correct
now let me let's just go back into
history
uh
were they in the middle ages at this
point any dissenting voice against their
system what happened to them
you were taken out of society they were
burnt at the stake right
any dissenting voice are we heading back
there
so are we making an image to the beast
are we thinking like it
are the mega corporations thinking like
it
now martin
once we understand this then we will
understand what scripture says when it
says we are making an image to the beast
now when god created man in his image
he created him
physically
but he also created him spiritually
right
so when we were in the image of god that
meant that the mindset was the same as
the mindset of god it was in harmony
with his character it was in harmony
with his principles it was in harmony
with his law
this system this antichrist system
also
has an image yeah
and the whole world must be in the image
of this antichrist in other words it
must have its mindset and that mindset
is a mindset that leads to death
according to the scripture
so it requires a choice right
here's the washington times from october
19 2021
block fake news pope francis begged
social media firms in the name of god
pope francis wants social media
companies to stop sharing fake news
pleading for such censorship
of purportedly open forums in the name
of god
it immediately brings back to me what
you've just said about the middle ages
it's exactly the same it's exactly the
same because who decides what's fake
news he does
you decided what you should believe in
the middle ages correct
so the 84 year old leader of the world's
1.2 billion roman catholic made his
comments in a video address to the
vatican-sponsored fourth world meeting
of popular movements
is the vatican behind all of these moral
meetings and
conjectures there's no doubt right
exactly
whose members he called social poets
francis spoke in spanish with english
subtitles appearing
on screen so we are basically
in
this phase of history where the image of
the beast is being set up
where the state
and the media which are all
interconnected are creating a virtual
world
which is in harmony with the thinking of
rom that's it
that's spot on and the thing is like we
will see later
anybody that's still thinking that
there's freedom or autonomy
out there
you'll see there is none no he is in
control of all now
as we can see
the restrictions are becoming more and
more right
it has to be
a very slow gentle approach otherwise
people might be along exactly you have
to take away the freedoms piece by piece
and provide so-called plausible reasons
as to why you are doing this and you
have to give some incentives
and some rewards yes for doing what they
want correct for some of their programs
i see that some brothels
are offering such incentives if you do
what we want you to do then you have
free access
i mean this is how ridiculous society
has become
revelation 13 verse 3 says and i saw one
of the heads as it were wounded to death
and the deadly wound was healed
and all the world wandered after the
beast and we look at that word we've had
it many times but we need to
focus on this issue
admire
have an admiration marvel
wander after the beast in other words
absorb its mindset yes and appreciate it
and
admire it and state that
he's the
moral authority of the earth
like kerry did
now martin
a virtual world
is a world of escape right
a world of escape from reality
now if you can create a virtual world of
escape from reality
then you can change reality
because people have a way of escaping it
yeah exactly
exactly are you getting what i'm saying
so they have a way of escaping it now
the primitive form of doing that
was to read novels yeah
so you took a novel
and you placed yourself into another
world
and you know the world and its problems
could go away because you were in
another world exactly
now
that was a very
dangerous forerunner of what is
happening now yes because then after
that you came it became
movies
correct and this will be movies on
steroids correct so now you had your you
had your your novels
and you could create anything you could
create a romantic world
you could create a violent world
you could create a perverse world
you could create anything you wanted to
suit every single taste
i wonder how many
marriages have ended on the rocks
because of novels
sickly sentimental little stories
of princes on white horses
when the reality is very different by
the sweat of your brow
right exactly so you create this you
create this utopic
idea
and reality is
so in contrast with it that your world
view is shattered
and
it's so interesting that when you read
the spirit of prophecy and you read
these statements that novels are
actually one of the means to create this
alternative reality and should be
avoided you think to yourself why
but as you see the progression you can
see where it leads
and this is such a dangerous thing but
this is where we are in the stream of
history
and how much further can you go than a
3d reality where you actually live
inside you actually climb inside your
book and become a character exactly
that's jesuit thinking
that is spiritual formation
that is jesuit theater
that is jesuit ignazian spirituality it
is
from
the pits of hell
and this is where the world is leading
and they came one of the seven angels
which had the seven vials and talked
with me saying unto me come heather
i will show unto thee the judgment of
the great that sits upon many
waters
so this church that sits upon
all the nations
with whom the kings of the earth have
committed fornication
so we know that the political realm is
under her spell
and the inhabitants of the earth
they have been made drunk with the wine
of a fornication they've started to
admire her
and think that she has a point
when she has turned reality
into virtual reality
revelation 13 verse 3 and i saw one of
the heads were wounded to death we're
talking about after the middle ages
right
and his deadly wound was healed and all
the world one did that little word
admired thought like it
became convinced like it
after the beast
seventeen verse five and upon a foreign
was a name written mystery a modern
mystery is something
that is
underground that's not visible that is
mysterious
babylon the great the mother of harlots
and abomination of the earth we will do
a whole series on
that we we've touched on it and many
times but perhaps for the time we are
living in we can just pull it all
together
and give
one where we actually talk about these
things
revelation 17 verse 7 and an angel said
unto me wherefore did thou marvel
i will tell thee the mystery of the
woman and of the beast that carries her
which has seven heads and ten horns
now this mystery
is then unfolded in the word of god and
we are told what her attributes are
and how often must god
display
her attributes to the world before he
will be believed seems to me over and
over right seems to me it's going to be
continually till the end
they just don't get it now no matter how
much blood flows
no matter how much freedom they gained
out of disassociating
they still want to associate that's why
the bible says associate yourselves
associate yourself right
john 18 20 jesus answered him i speak
openly to the world i ever taught in the
synagogue and in the temple whether the
jews always resort
and in secret have i said
nothing
what did this uh meta
representative just say
that it it's it's still unclear it's
cloaked in mystery and secrecy and
secrecy how much they actually are doing
these
abominable eggs ephesians 5 11 says have
no fellowship with the unfruitful works
of darkness but rather reprove them for
it is a shame even to speak of those
things which are done of them
in secret
god is so opposed to this cloak of
secrecy that they wrap themselves into
and this is a kind of preparation for
cop26
because if you do not understand the
language of cop26
you will think that nothing happened
but in actual fact
once you start decoding their
terminology
you can see what they're actually
planning in secret yeah
they don't work that
devil doesn't work
openly
he's keeping you busy with one hand
while the other one is doing whatever he
wants to he's like a magician
an illusionist
counsels for the church page 335 god has
revealed what is to take place in the
last days that his people may be
prepared to stand against the tempest of
opposition and wrath
those who have been warned of the events
before them are not to sit in calm
expectation of the coming storm
comforting themselves that the lord will
shelter his faithful ones in the day of
trouble
we are to be as men waiting for the lord
not in idol expectancy but in earnest
work with unwavering faith
it is no time now to allow our minds to
be engrossed with things of minor
importance
while men are sleeping
satan is actively arranging matters so
that the lord's people may not have
mercy or justice
the sunday movement is now making its
way in darkness that's in secrecy isn't
it yep
leaders are concealing the true issue
and many who unite in the movement do
not themselves see whether the
undercurrent is tending
its professions are mild and apparently
christian
but when it shall speak it will reveal
the spirit of the dragon
this is
very important council
and because
this movement is making its way in
secret
god's people are allowed to sleep
they don't see anything
they are in a virtual snoring paradise
all right now we've shown many of these
before
but let's just once again reiterate
the bible says the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast
now
do we see the kings of the world
constantly going to any other individual
on this planet on a regular basis other
than the pope
i don't see it
i don't see it either so reality and not
virtual reality tells us that this is a
fact
the kings of the world whether they are
from the west like in the case of donald
trump or whether they are from the east
block makes no difference
they end up
there
and they are greeted equally heartily
whether they're from the left or from
the right whether they're from the east
or from the west or from the north or
the south
and
here we have biden and the pope together
angela merkel and the pope together and
they seem very happy to be in each
other's company right
and emmanuel macron of course
so just a few of the kings of the world
that are preparing to give their power
unto the beast
and then you have the ceos of the mega
companies
you have tim cook
ceo of apple
then you have mark
zuckerberg founder of facebook and now
meta and now meta
and then you have kevin systrom ceo of
instagram
do you think there is something
happening
behind the scenes here or is just
just a friendly a visit to your neighbor
if you listen to the pope's words
and what he asks
then the
fake news in the name of god and all
this and then you see it happen
then i think if you put the two together
you can see his influence is quite
drastic now martin if he says
ban the fake news
then he implies that you mustn't i
mustn't ban his news
so by definition his news is not fake
news
and anything that is contrary to his
news must be fake news
right yeah now if he is working in
secrecy and according to the scripture
is the antichrist then isn't his version
fake news
yes and the fake news
is the real news
now you can get very confused because
you can put fake news within real news
as well
but that is where you need filters
exactly and where do you get the filters
the bible and the spirit of prophecy
we're back to square one right
so you know these people that shout fake
news should first use the filter exactly
to see who is spreading the fake news
just something that popped up in my mind
now there was actually a a snippet of
where
i think it was twitter
was fact-checking itself because it put
out a statement
and immediately the counter statement
that this is not true came up in their
own
in their own facts check
that's interesting
so they facts check each other
and then of course
we have the religious world so
what have we got now we've got the
political world the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast
then the merchants
that no longer sell her wares
that's a very interesting statement in
revelation chapter 18.
her wares
now what are her wares
are we talking only about products or
are we talking about ideology yes
ideology will definitely have to be part
of it
so
we know that the merchants of the world
are associated with that also with our
ideology
and there are some interesting adverts
where products are being advertised
without advertising the product at all
but merely a morality associated with
the organization right yes that's
happened recently with a lot of
adverts perhaps we can put some of that
into a future what's up right
we can do that
so we also know that the religious world
the children
will associate with us so you had
kenneth copeland and you had rick warren
the so-called father of the protestant
world
and you had the panthus panti philipus
musa the president of the lutheran world
federation and any other religious
leader that you can think of in the
world of any prominence they've also
been there not even only christian
exactly buddhists
islam
now let us get closer to our current
topic
which is cop 26.
we know that uh biden had a meeting with
the pope just prior to cop 26 then he
had a meeting with the g20
and then finally they went to cop26
right god love you
says cnn politics warm relationship
between the world's most powerful
catholics on display
as biden and pope francis
meet after
biden said francis had told him he was
pleased he was a good catholic
and that he should continue receiving
communion despite opposition from some
conservative american bishops over his
support for abortion
biden's meeting friday was heavy with
symbolism for the nation's second
catholic president who attends mass
almost every week
making the sign of the cross during his
speeches and displays a photo of francis
in the oval office alongside frames of
his wife and grandchildren
so martin here we have two people
obviously of the same mindset
so are they reflecting the same image
yes
spiritually speaking definitely
absolutely right
revelation 13 verse 14 says and he
deceives them that dwell on the earth by
means of the miracles which he had power
to do in the sight of the beast
saying to them that dwell on the earth
that they should make an image to the
beast which had the wound by a sword and
did live
so it must have the same mindset
it must admire the first one to such an
extent that it wants to incorporate that
mindset into its legislation
and he had power to give life unto the
image of the beast that the image of the
beast should both speak and cause
as many as would not worship the image
of the beast that they should be killed
now how does a political system which is
a beast
speak and cause
through legislation yeah
it's the only way
so you either
shape up
or you ship out right
you either come into harmony with this
mindset or there is no place for you
correct and they will
obviously that's why we're going to talk
about it use certain means that can
incorporate
all of humanity correct
now if you are well known
through your dogmas for example
to be opposed to the very basics of this
beast power
then you should be a special target
right
and the dragon was roth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed
they that
keep the commandments of god yes
so martin before cop 26 actually took
place there was this with visit by biden
there was also the visit by religious
leaders the the political leaders were
there
it was a very busy time yes of
preparation
so the pub didn't actually have to be at
cop 26 because the work
was actually done before right
so
the cop 26 was basically a rubber stamp
let's have a look at some of the
meetings that took place there
the pope met with politicians from
different countries who were in rome to
prepare for the upcoming climate change
conference in glasgow united states
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
president of the italian chamber of
deputies roberto fico were present
representative
pope francis said that overcoming the
climate crisis requires a shift in
attitude beginning with global leaders
i met
he also asked for more solidarity among
countries to address climate change
together
in fact
the pope will not travel to glasgow for
cop 26 but he has been actively
promoting the upcoming climate
conference which will begin on october
31st asking participants to reach
concrete and ambitious agreements
well we can see who the main
person there is right the one sitting in
front dressed in white
it's interesting that you can see the
swiss guard standing in the back there
the symbol
of
his protection by the swiss
and it's interesting martin
that the swiss government has now opened
its embassy
in the vatican as well
whereas before it worked through a
subsidiary
so it seems as if the nations are
rapidly coming on board right
and this is before cop 26 a very good
preparation we could also show the
videos on the religious meetings and the
signing of the religious accord in
preparation for cop
26. then time magazine gave it an
interesting title the last call
sounds almost like the last invitation
to humanity right
maybe it can be
yeah maybe it can be followed with a
light loud cry from the other side
correct and then there were two chairs
that were noteworthy empty
namely the chinese delegation and the
russian delegation
there must always be some form of
conflict it mustn't appear to cut and
dried
but all of those individuals were with
the vatican before anyway so
really is this uh reality or is this
cloak and dagger stuff
and they had a cut out of the queen
because she was too ill to attend
but she was there in a virtual capacity
i think they could have done better and
put it there in a hologram
but
the pope himself too
he also
was absent
but he'd done his work already exactly
so there's a very interesting picture
and it's also very interesting
that the front row here in the center is
occupied
by the one that represents the second
beast
of revelation
and of course the news is always very
interesting when it comes to these
things but you'll only see what happens
on the surface yeah we'll never see what
happens underneath
for that you have to dig a little deeper
and uh here's an here's a news broadcast
from sky news australia
and uh they are really quite blunt
sometimes so let them say it rather than
us right
okay let's have a bit of a look at
what's going on in glasgow hey as i said
china russia and india have snubbed it
effectively they've played the rest of
the world for suckers i guess but the
conference has started to hear from some
leading figures all going with the same
save the planet mantra of course but all
in their different styles let's start
with some dignity the queen sent a video
message urging the leaders to get the
job done for future generations
i for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and achieve true statesmanship
fat chance ma'am fat chance for instance
you're jibbering full of a son you're
heir apparent he gave an address that
might have come from fidel castro
we know this will take trillions not
billions of dollars
we also know that countries many of whom
are burdened
by growing levels of debt
simply cannot afford to go green
here we need a vast military style
campaign to marshal the strength of the
global private sector
that was comrade charles i mean prince
charles despite all this radical talk of
up ending global economics politics
business and trade it wasn't enough for
perhaps the youngest but biggest name in
glasgow greta tunberg
change is not going to come from inside
there that is not leadership
leadership looks like
this this is
we say no more blah blah blah no more
exploitation of people and nature and
the planets no more exploitation no more
blah blah blah
no more whatever they're doing inside
there
[Applause]
yeah but these climate conferences are
so surreal that the rhetorical
flourishes of the teenage radical
activists found their way into the
arguments of the conference host
boris johnson he pointed out to the all
the commitments made in the previous
commitments of conferences leading up to
glasgow
and all those promises will be nothing
but blah blah blah
to coin a phrase
and the anger and the impatience of the
world will be uncontainable
unless we make this cop 26 in glasgow
the moment when we get real about
climate change
i think they made vax the word of the
year this year i reckon it might be blah
blah blah next year so glasgow with its
private jets famous supporters and giant
entourages might generate more emissions
than it cuts
and it won't be taken seriously by the
extremists that it's trying to placate
so martin
let's not get involved in blah blah blah
what is blah blah blah blah blah blah is
what the world is supposed to see
what happens behind the scenes is more
interesting than blah blah blah
and we don't have to add to the comments
of sky news i think they did a fair
enough job
we could add a few more adjectives but
we could also leave it at that
so
what really happened over there now
there have been ministries that have
done an excellent work in exposing some
of the things that are happening behind
the scenes
so
there are people on this planet
that are actually aware of what is
happening and are filtering things
through the bible and the spirit of
prophecy yes
and
some of the the things which are being
said are i think very relevant
so here is un climate change conference
uk
2021 and it comes from the 4th of
november
and we will look at some of the
buzzwords which they use behind which
they hide their intentions
where they work in darkness
and this one says supporting the
conditions for a just transition
internationally
this sounds like klaus schwab
all right yeah
we are going to have a just transition
but the word just transition is a
buzzword
and you will have to find it in
different
connotations in order to see what they
are saying yes it's almost like built
back better
yes
and when they all start saying it and
when this mantra is repeated over and
over
then it's perhaps time to start digging
into what are they actually saying
because it's a code word for something
else right
the paris agreement preamble reflects
the close links between climate action
sustainable development and a just
transition there's the word
with parties to the agreement taking
into account the imperative of a just
transition of the workplace
and the creation of a decent work and
quality jobs in accordance with
nationally defined
development priorities
the international labor organization
guidelines for a just transition that's
the harmonious time that we're reading
it now
negotiated between governments
employers and their organizations
as well as workers
and their trade unions established a
global understanding for the term just
transition
they're making a point are they not
it described it as a process towards an
environmentally sustainable economy
which needs to be well managed and
contribute to the goals of decent work
for all that's another codeword yes
decent work
social inclusion and the eradication of
poverty now there are many many
things in this statement
and the ilo is the international labor
organization and that is directly
affiliated with the united nations it is
the overseeing body
and it also represents of course trade
unions
and
workers through the trade union so it's
a grass root
supposedly movement now when we go back
into the history of trade unions where
did they start
at
rome
in the vatican that is where they
started
and the early trade unions
uh they have the nuns working etc etc
creating this image and creating this
this utopia for
the worker almost a virtual reality it's
a virtual reality you're right
okay so
just transition we need to unpack that
and see what it means
and then we ask ourselves at this cop
meeting
what was actually decided that nobody
really talks about
and
it was this
just transition
in cooperation
with the trade unions of the world
represented by the international labour
organization of the united nations
and it was signed by the governments of
the united kingdom belgium canada the
government of the kingdom of denmark the
european union
the government of the french republic
the government of the federal republic
of germany greece the government of the
italian republic
so even though the european
union is mentioned there they mentioned
them individually as well just to make
sure
the government of the netherlands the
government of new zealand the government
of the kingdom of norway the government
of the republic of poland the government
of spain the government of kingdom of
sweden and the federal government of the
united states
all of them there now who are sitting in
the front row of that time picture
united states the united states of
america it will be the key player
in terms of the signatory
if we turn to south africa here's a
statement from the government webpage
and it says president presidency on
international partnership to support a
just transition
same terminology
to a low carbon economy and a climate
resilient society so president cyril
ramaphosa has today tuesday 2nd november
joined other leaders in announcing a
historic partnership with the
governments of and then we have the list
again france germany united kingdom
united states as well as european union
to support a just transition to a
low-carbon economy and a
climate-resilient society in south
africa
so it's interesting that is followed by
this statement here in preparation for
cop 26 south africa submitted
a revised nationally determined
contribution which is known as ndc
basically martin as i understand it each
government
to
certain actions within its sphere
and without this commitment and without
this document you have no place in cop
correct and you have to adhere to your
ndc and you had to adhere to the
commitment now the south african
power industry is heavily based on coal
so through the political declaration
issued today to establish this
partnership partner countries will
mobilize an initial 8.5 billion
over the next three
to five years through a range of
instruments including grants and
concessional finance
to support the implementation of our
revised ndc
through a just transcision
to a low carbon and climate resilient
economy so all these nations are on
board with their ndc's and their just
transition correct and the just
transition is part of the labor drive
right
it's very important that we understand
that and that cop 26 scientists
documentation and now what's interesting
is if you take south africa
these other partners
because we are not financially strong
enough to do it on our own
they make sure that there will be enough
to get this whole movement in the
implemented but let's just let's just
get some
outcome from this this sounds so nice
and so rosy
and they have been supplied with 8.5
billion dollars in order to create some
of this transition
now what happens to all the privately
owned companies that deal in the
previous technology
what will happen to them they'll have to
go okay so where will this 8.5 billion
be distributed to to these private
companies or will it be into
organizations that are well established
within the sphere of power
so basically what we can see here is
that there is a lot of money
going into it but that money is going in
a particular direction
and will basically get rid of the middle
class
and private enterprises
so in order to understand how the
ramifications work
we have to understand
government and labor
working together to implement the image
of the bees
right
of course religion as well so there must
be something that labor wants
and there must be something that
religion wants
and then there must be something that is
absolutely in harmony with what the
beast wants yes correct otherwise it
doesn't make any sense
so let's see
what biden had to say about the
international labor organization
hi everyone i want to thank the
international labor organizations for
everything you do
just as it did when this organization
was founded a century ago
democracy faces another test now
the autocrats of the world believe
democracy can't compete in the 21st
century they became emboldened and now
they're coming after the rights of
workers and the international labor
standards that have long identified the
ilo
they're betting
we can't come through for working people
but they're wrong
all right let's unpack that a little bit
martin
so is he on board with the international
labor organization yep he's definitely
absolutely right
and he's he's linking it to democracy
democracy
is where the people apparently have a
choice to make
but who's making the choice here the
international labor organization right
is that democracy no or is that implied
democracy yes because they do it on
behalf of the people but they do as they
see fit correct
and what they see fit is what has been
impressed upon them by a higher power
before
so we have to we have to see that
connection
so this is no longer
democracy martin this is coercion of the
highest level it's it's actually
brilliant because it's coercion without
you knowing its conversion correct under
the umbrella
of something else
i'm it's like i'll tell you what's best
for you
correct so now let's just make sure
we have to get these connections here's
the vatican news pope to the ilo
urgent need for economic reform and
protection of all workers so here you
can see the pope there on the screen and
standing in the front there in a meeting
with all the hard hats
representing the man in the street the
laborer that's why it's democracy
but the organization is ruled and run by
figures that is anything but democracy
so marking 109 years since the founding
of the international labor organization
pope francis sends a video message in
which he stresses the importance of the
rights of workers each worker in each
form of work especially as we come out
of this coveted 19 pandemic in hope of
economic recovery the rights of workers
now under the rights of
workers we must never forget
that even in
which is the main document
which deals with the workers right
the right to sunday rest is a paramount
important
aspect yes
he went on to add that the protection of
workers and the most vulnerable must be
ensured through the respect of their
fundamental rights including the right
to organize in unions
that is explained the pope organizing in
unions is a right
spirit of prophecy tells us it is one of
the means to bring about a time of
trouble such as never was
it is the conviction of the holy see
that work and therefore workers can
count on guarantees support and
empowerment if they are protected from
the game of deregulation said the pope
legal norms must be geared towards
employment growth decent work
and the right and duties of the human
person he added now this
decent work is another code
so everything is hidden in code yes you
have to find and unpack what do they
mean with decent work so you have a just
transition you have a decent work
and you have an organization
which pays lip service
to
rerun
exactly to the pope to his encyclicals
so let's have a look at the
international labor organization's own
web page
guidelines for a just transition towards
environmentally sustainable economies
and societies for all
again you have the buzzwords just just
transition
and it's also interesting just to note
how they bring all of this together
you've got religion in here you've got
climate change in your
the whole
swarm of things are
bundled together now why do they do that
because you need distraction exactly if
it was so clear-cut
then
maybe god's people could wake up
but if you do it this way they can keep
on snoring right
so what is their vision
the four pillars are
the decent work agenda there's the
buzzword
social dialogue social protection right
at work and employment are indispensable
building blocks for its sustainable
development
and prince charles of course is the
ultimate sustainable prince
and must be at the center of policies
for strong sustainable and inclusive
growth and development
let's look at decent work
poverty eradication environmental
sustainability are three of the defining
challenges of the 21st century
economies must be productive to meet the
needs of the world's growing population
societies must be inclusive
providing opportunities for decent work
for all reducing inequalities and
effectively eliminating poverty
it's all couched in very nice buzzwords
right yes
now let's have a look at the religious
organization by the way the ilo in its
documentation
also in sconces sunday as a worker's
right which the state must guarantee
is exactly what they are doing and if
you now going to take rerum navaram
it brings it all together and they're
doing actually what the vatican wants
them to do correct so now you have the
labor unions wanting
sunday rest
and you know when they started this
european sunday alliance
there were signatories
public signatories to this from all
walks of government
all churches and interestingly
virtually all the labor unions as well
so it shows this
decided
agreement
on this issue by all of these parties
so you european sunday alliance
conference on a work free sunday and
decent work
they work together so you have labor
and you have religion asking for exactly
the same thing and this is
giving a definition to decent work
let's have a look
the pledge states that a work free
sunday
and decent working hours
are of paramount importance for citizens
and workers throughout europe and are
not necessarily in conflict with
economic competitiveness
especially in the present time of
socio-economic crisis
the adoption of legislation extending
working hours to late evenings nights
bank holidays and sundays
has direct consequences for the working
conditions of employees
and for small and medium-sized
enterprises competitiveness needs
innovation innovation needs creativity
and creativity needs recreation so
decent work
implies sunday keeping that's it
in a nutshell
so basically when the governments at cop
signed this agreement
with the international labor
organization
they were signing an agreement for the
implementation of sunday legislation if
you want to put it bluntly that's
exactly that's exactly what they did yes
but it's in darkness exactly you can't
see it
all right martin so let's just tie labor
and government together
here is uh marty welch speaking
and he is the secretary of labor
and you have joe biden so let's have a
look at what they have to say
we were just back in in the green room
and the president was talking to
president shuler and jocelyn and he said
this is labor's house
and how often do you hear that
i want to welcome everyone to the white
house and i really mean that
this is your house it's not hyperbole
it's a fact this is your house i
wouldn't be here without you
that's again not hyperbole
in my white house
you'll always be welcome always be
welcome labor will always be welcome
you know you've heard me uh say many
times i intend to be the most pro-union
president
leading the most pro-union
administration in american history
but i think one of the reasons i'm able
to do that is the public is changing too
you've changed the public you've
educated them a lot
and every day we remember
that america wasn't built by wall street
they're not all bad folks on wall street
i'm not suggesting that
but they didn't build america
it was built by the middle class
and unions built the middle class
martin
do you think that what he just said was
the truth or the distortion of the truth
i think it's a distortion of the truth i
see so the labor unions built the middle
class i think the middle class
built
in spite of the labor union exactly but
leave that as it may be he also said
that the labor unions
educated the masses
by sheer force of numbers by having all
the workers in their camp
they have become a formidable voice
for the people
but how do you educate the people with a
particular mindset right you put it back
like we've seen with international
labour law correct now whose mindset are
they educating the people with
isn't that the mindset of the very ones
that praised them and told them what
their marching orders were wasn't that
the vatican
so let's have a look at marty welch and
how does he fit into the picture let's
just get some
information about this united states
secretary of labor
he initially dropped out of college
he later took night classes as an adult
and received a bachelor of arts degree
in social science from the woods college
of advancing studies at boston college
in 2009 and he joined the labor unions
local at the age of 21 and served as the
union's president until he became the
mayor of boston
in 2015 waltz launched the climate ready
boston initiative to prepare boston for
the effects of climate change you see
how this all fits together and of course
boston college can you tell us something
about boston college it's a jesuit
college oh a jesuit college isn't it
strange
it's coincidence probably yes of course
conspiracy
walsh served in the leadership of c40
cities climate leadership group he is a
roman catholic obviously he speaks irish
so
the plan has come together all the
parties are sitting
around the same table let's read great
controversy
and then the great deceiver will
persuade men that those who serve god
are causing these evils the class that
have provoked the displeasure of heaven
will charge all their troubles upon
those whose obedience to god's
commandments is a perpetual reproof to
transgressors
martin let's get them off the air let's
get the social media companies to shadow
ban them and then ban them entirely yeah
and even do it in the name of god and do
it in the name of god it will be
declared that men are offending god by
the violation of the sunday sabbath that
this sin has brought calamities which
will not cease until sunday observance
shall be strictly enforced that those
who present the claims of the fourth
commandment
thus destroying reverence for sunday are
troublers of the people
preventing their restoration to divine
favor and temporal prosperity
is the table led
yes for sure everybody is ready to eat
right
thus the accusation urged of old against
the servant of god will be repeated and
upon the grounds equally well
established
and it came to pass when ahab saw elijah
that abel ahab said unto him art thou he
that troubleth israel
and he answered i have not troubled
israel but thou in thy father's house
in that year forsaken the commandments
of the lord and has followed balaam
as the wrath of the people shall be
excited by false charges
they will pursue a course towards god's
ambassadors very similar to that which
apostate israel
pursued towards elijah
who was ahab married to jesus
and jezebel serves as a type
of roman catholicism exactly because you
read in the middle church theater that
there was a jezebel there
and that she dealt with the colors
purple and crimson
which are the colors of rome
so
in other words the modern ahab the
leaders of the world including joe biden
are in bed with jezebel
and jezebel
led people into sun worship
you tolerate that woman
who led her into sun worship now sunday
is a very
integral part of sun
worship
and the venerable day of the sun
it was called
martin this is a direct attack upon the
authority of god
and it's taking the real world of god
and transforming it into a virtual world
of the imagination and it's done so
cleverly that that it looks like it's
actually
in favor of what god would want it looks
like it but it is the exact antithesis
well let's see whether this
labor organization etc
can lead by example
here's an article in eddie the first
week of cop 26 the 10 biggest stories
it's half time on the two-week push to
move the world towards the 1.5 degree
centigrade ambition
of the paris agreement with the
negotiations set to continue following a
rest day on sunday
7th of november yeah eddie summarizes
all the key developments from the first
week of cop 26. they're leading by
example
they're leading by example they're
telling us in code where they are going
the journal america the jesuit review
pope francis failure to fight climate
change will incur god's judgment
we just read about that in the great
controversy correct and if you fail to
acknowledge his directives and he's
then martin you will incur another god's
which happens to be him right yes and
they will cause as many as will not
worship the beast to be
killed
world leaders are running out of time
and must address the challenges of
climate change before it's too late pope
francis said time is running out
this occasion must not be wasted you
know what i'm so glad time is running
out
i'm so glad he's on a short fuse yes
because this means that the lord is
coming soon right
he's in such a rush
and god's people are sleeping how do you
explain that unbelievable
this occasion must not be wasted lest we
have to face god's judgment for our
failure to be faithful stewards of the
world
he has entrusted to our care he wrote at
the summit the united states and china
announced november 10 that a joint
agreement was signed between the two
countries in an effort to lower
greenhouse gas emissions this is very
interesting
because china was absent exactly
but it's in the bag
it's just for appearances it must be
a diverting tactic
they must be looking in different
directions so that you do not see what
is happening in darkness
god forbid that god's people should wake
up
this would be the greatest calamity for
the purpose he wants everything in the
bag
before the loud cry
he thanked catholics in scotland for
joining him in prayer for the conference
which is meant to address one of the
great model issues of our time
the preservation of god's creation
given to us as a garden to be cultivated
and as a common home for our human
family and he's already told us in
loddar to see
what that model issue is we must keep
sunday the labor unions have said that
the churches are saying at the papacy is
saying it
and biden is praising the labor unions
the lutheran world federation we've done
has shown this many times is on board
with this jubilee of the earth
and what's interesting to me
if we talk to somebody about the
saturday sabbath of the lord
they say oh but
you want to keep a day to get in favor
with god
but they seem to forget that now that
they want to implement and there has
been laws blue laws on books of every
country almost in the world
then it wasn't a problem to have laws
for god's sunday to be kept correct as
long as it's their law yeah and not
god's law
now
another interesting side issue
is this report in the jerusalem post
that michael flynn calls for u.s to have
only one religion
that's very interesting right
do you think that one religion would
then
be a minority religion or a majority
religion majority must be right if we're
going to have one nation under god
which we must we have to have one
religion flynn said saturday at a rally
in texas for reawakening america a
christian themed speaking tour backed by
the christian news network america faith
one nation under god and one religion
under god
imagine that sounds to me like making
christianity in its broad sense
and the religion and now if i want if
you have to think
this is the christian rally going on and
they calling for this one religion so
obviously it will have to be the
christian religion and what day do they
upheld
sunday sunday so i that's just what i
want to emphasize when i
well what i mentioned earlier
it's not a problem
for them to emphasize sunday keeping
correct but later let's down play
saturday and the sabbath and just you
mentioned saturday then you're a
legalist and the pub has already opined
that what binds christians together is
that they all keep sunday
but of course he neglects those that
don't right
so basically martin
what we are seeing here is a
pronged attack from
all of these organizations
and hidden in their terminology
you have sunday legislation
ensconced
and
the axiom all roads lead to rome
is
as verily truth as it has always been
and
we are living in the very tippy toes
of earth's history
and we need to discuss modern how we're
going to deal what is going to come upon
us with blinding force
so perhaps in our next ones we can look
at some practical issues how to survive
in a time like this
and we can look at
summaries of
the flow of events so that we can
be grounded and firm and understand
what the word of god is telling us about
the times that we are living in
and rather than using this for
fear-mongering
let us rather say lift up your heads
because you know that your redemption
draweth nigh amen let's pray
heavenly father
this sunday movement has indeed been
making its way in darkness
but it is coming to fruition
and the legal frameworks have been set
and they are international
legal
frameworks
give us the wisdom
and the understanding which comes
through your word
to embrace the truth and to stand with
it though the heavens fall is my prayer
in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here
thank you